as the x-men square off against
apocalypse and his four horsemen there's
no shortage of spoiler if ik c Crenn sin
the latest mutant slugfest if there's
anything to learn from apocalypse taking
on Professor X's band of Heroes it's
that the 1980s and the ancient evil
villain are both pretty much immortal
put on your neon colored parachute pants
we've made you an x-men apocalypse
Easter egg omelet so dense you'll need
adamantium claws to cut through it and
just in case you missed it here's your
final warning
there are major spoilers ahead jabs at
the last stand
one of x-men apocalypse is most meta
Easter eggs comes while some young
mutants pull a Ferris Bueller and ditch
a school day hitting up the mall instead
surprisingly the Dazzler record scene
we've seen in pictures prior to the
film's release was nowhere to be found
in the actual film instead the group
takes a few jabs at the more
underwhelming parts of the x-men film
franchise as the four mutant teens leave
a showing of return to the Jedi they
joke about how sequels always end up
being much darker than the first film
even though they're talking about Star
Wars
it's also a pretty clear reference to x2
X Men United gene gray adds that
everyone knows that the third movie is
almost always the weakest of the bunch
which is almost definitely a zinger
aimed at x-men The Last Stand the third
moving the franchise that most fans
pretend never happened in case you were
wondering
frequent x-men director Bryan Singer
skipped out on filming The Last Stand in
favor of Superman Returns return of the
blob in a callback to Wolverines debut
in the original x-men film and x-men
origins Wolverine we're treated to some
mutant filled underground fights before
we see angel taking on Nightcrawler we
see a familiar face laid out on the
ground from a previous fight this is
Fred Dukes better known as the blob
dudes being flat on his back is probably
a callback to his appearance in origins
this time he looks even more comic
accurate good luck to the guys who had
to carry him out of the ring
Star Trek appreciation Bryan Singer
isn't ashamed of being a Trekkie
when we visit storms home her television
is playing the original Star Trek series
season 2 episode who mourns for a
geneious this Trek episode foreshadows
future events with apocalypse as it
focuses on the team encountering a
powerful godlike character who can grow
to amazing Heights sound familiar
singer also appeared as an uncredited
crew member in Star Trek nemesis taking
orders from the
professor Eck's himself Patrick Stewart
Stanley's cameo co-star we've seen Stan
Lee cameo as a postman Hugh Hefner Larry
King and intergalactic ladies man and
even a strip club DJ get made up in
x-men apocalypse these role is much
simpler we see him react to something
horrific the big difference from his
previous cameos is who's with him this
time around with Lee during the scene is
his real-life wife Joan reloading weapon
X the last x-men apocalypse trailer
teased Hugh Jackman's returned for the
we've lost counting time as Wolverine
the film gives Logan his adamantium
skeleton from the Weapon X program
rewriting origins story even further
along with his trademark trauma-induced
berserker rage
best of all Jackman actually wears the
iconic Weapon X headgear straight from
the comics don't hold your breath for
the characters famous yellow spandex
costume though another order of the
Phoenix
speaking of Wolverine the characters
longtime love interest Jean Grey is only
in her teens during the film and she's
still struggling to control her powers
Jean Grey has nightmares about what's
going to happen teasing the inevitable
fight against apocalypses forces she
also alludes to seeing flames and a
darkness inside of her
foreshadowing her character's eventual
possession by the cosmic entity known as
the Phoenix in both x-men The Last Stand
and the original comic books Jean
struggles with controlling the fiery
Phoenix before it takes over completely
turning her into one of the series most
powerful villains toward the end of
x-men apocalypse Jean throws her worries
out the window after Xavier tells her to
go all out on apocalypse
Jean turns her powers on full blast
resulting in a flaming bird aura around
her teasing the Phoenix for a future
entry of the series yes we got chills
from it and so will you hopefully if
they revisit the Phoenix saga in future
movies it'll go a little better this
time around that sinister post-credit
scene as usual the movie's post-credit
scene will leave comic junkies jumping
for joy while the average moviegoer will
just have to wait until the comic fan
explains it to them the final scene
features a man in suit exploring the
ruins of William strikers Weapon X
compound as a cleanup crew tries mopping
up the mess of bullets and bodies the
man grabbed some Weapon X samples and
Stowe's them in his briefcase the
briefcase snap shut
showing a logo of a company named SX
Corp comic fans know that Nathaniel
Essex also known as miss
sinister is a longtime villain of the
x-men he frequently collaborates with
apocalypse and he's obsessed with Jean
Grey and Scott Summers genetics he goes
as far as creating a clone of Jean Grey
Madeleine Pryor who's Scott Summers
marries and has a kid with that kid
turns out to be Cable Deadpool's
time-traveling buddy this could set up
mr. sinister at a future x-men film and
maybe even the fan favorite character of
x-23 a young female clone of Wolverine
the 20th Century Fox is looking for a
way to make more Wolverine movies after
Hugh Jackman hangs up his claws bringing
x-23 into the fold may just do the trick
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Easter Egg
from x-men apocalypse was your favorite